Yarr, anybody in there?
Okay, no? Alright then...
*Animatronic and Mark scream*
Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to The Joy of Creation: Story Mode. Now, it's time to go into the basement
We don't know what's waiting for us in the basement, but I have a funny feeling it's Bonnie, Freddy, Chica and Foxy.
Maybe a little of Golden Freddy because I think I remember,
in the office sometimes when you were going for Freddy-
Nick: "Do you believe in Spirits?"
Mark: Little more...
Narrarator:"Many do."
"Many claim they've seen one, or have heard stories of people being haunted by these white figures or oily shadows..."
"My dad made a game series about it- of the horror franchise, in fact. It was his shining achievement."
"Apparently, there was a time when everybody knew about it. All over the world: clothing, toys...
...accessories, board games- you name it. Five Nights at Freddy's was everywhere. There are even rumors they're beginning a movie!"
*Awkward Chuckle*
"Well..."
"It didn't last long anyway..."
"Nobody remembers it anymore, nor the characters the games... OR my father."
"After that night it... all went away."
"Nothing lasts forever, and that's why I don't believe in spirits."
"Everyone has to die. Everything has an end at some point."
Nick: "Even if that point comes sooner than you'd wish."
Mark: *Babbling "there's something in that window. It's Freddy"*
Mark: Hey Freddy, hello, okay, alright! What does that have to do with going in the basement!? That's awfully that's also a really sad view of the- whoa
Scott: "Hello!? Kids?"
Scott: "Are any of you there? I found your note- Daddy's here! You must be really scared, but-but I'm here"
Mark: Okay
I don't know what to... *disgusted reaction*
Oh boy, this looks bad. I think I remember bad memories--
*Animatronic scream and Scott's surprised shout*
--About the basement with foxy in it when the demo is-
Scott: "Why are you doing this to us- Why!? Just leave us all alone, you monsters!"
"I created you!"
"Freddy, Bonnie, Chica..."
"Foxy..."
"How? How is this happening? What are you!?"
"You are NOT them... You're just using their faces. What are you!?"
Mysterious voice: "Your creations..."
Scott: "What-"
Mark: Ow...
???: "I'm sorry."
Was that Michael talking? Is that who that *accent* was?
Ooh. Press x- oh, WASD to move, left click to interact with items, f to turn the flashlight on and off. OH....
Good...
GOOD...
Good, good. *singing* Let's doooo this! Let's doooo this! Let's go into the darkness and do this. Oh boy.
I bet I'm gonna wake up in the inner machinations of some saw-type
disaster here, where someone is going to "test me" and if I don't succeed, I will die a horrible death.
*Flashlight click*
*Gasp* Oh
Ooh, okay. Alright. Alright, okay...
Ah, good, yes, you put me in the SHITTY toilet. Oh good, thank you for that. Why is this in my basement?
I have no idea.
*drawn out* Oh!
*reading*"You are awake."
Yes. I- oh- hi. Hello. This is so cool, but also so creepy. *reading* "You exist to let us out."
Okay, alright, then...
*reading* "Let us out."
*reading* "Open the way."
*reading*"Or burn with the rest of them."
You had more monitors, you could have put 'of them'...
*intrigued and scared tone, drawn out*
Oh!
What were those? Those were some conspicuous looking other monstrosities... And what is that? Is that my child's bedroom?
Or is that my bedroom? Why do I have cameras in my house?
Why, oh this is so creepy. If this is it all real. I don't even know if it is.
Am I not gonna get any information about this one
Or am I just going to be left to my own devices? There seems to be a lot of six on the walls here
S'that have something to do with what I need to do? Why- who built this?
*high pitched yelling* Who built this? Who the helly-hell built this? Who the bingle bonger binker built this bullshit.
Ooh.
*Mechanical childs laughter*
Uh oh
Well that seems bad. Well then obviously that doesn't work so, is there something else down here?
Okay
Whaat was that? That was like a game over screen from the last few nights. What was that all about?
Come back?
Hello?
OH HI.
Who are you?!
*suspicious tone, drawn out*
Oh!
*Anamatronic scream and Mark yells*
Fucking God dammit.
Oooh.
Holy *drawn out*  Fuck.
Shitty dickie balls.
Okay, so I can't get close to that thing. Maybe I got to get through the door.
*quietly* Oh boy, oh boy. Nope. This is gonna kill me
This is gonna kill me. He's gonna kill me. Oh
*Whispered*: How do I get back in?
I'm not sure what to do about that. Maybe I- I'm gonna try to sneak over to the bathroom again
*Mark whimpers*
*Door squeaks open*
*Door slam*
*Flash light click*
Why did I come in here? I didn't need to come in here.
*Door squeak*
Oh! Ah!
*reading* "We come from the fire."
Ahh.
*reading* "But our bodies need shape."
Huh? Oh, wha? "Bring his creations to us." I don't-
"To ignite our flame."
I don't know. What are you talking about?
I need a cupcake. I need a triangle. I need a swirkly-doo. I need a *stutters* a role?
I don't know where any of those are.
Oh, but I need to bring 'em. Is that what I gotta do? Is that what I gotta do.
Do I gotta go back and forth in this bullshit.
Over and over again.
While avoiding death.
Is that what I gotta do?
Ohh I don't like this. Oh, God. "You Rock.". "Are You Ready?" no.
Okay. AIH- "You are not safe." I know I'm not safe.
Go back where?
Uh uh ah uh uh ah aH AHH
I don't know what I'm dun to do
Tag you're it. Oh, God. That was a bad idea. Oh I shouldn't be up here.
Ohhhhhhh
Oh no, was I suppose to go back? Oh no
*panicked, loudly* Uh oh, uh oh. Oh, God
Hey, no, no, no
*Mark whispered* ah fuck, ah fuck
Anyone in here? Anyone in here? Going back. I can't run or anything so I gotta just- Yeah!
Oh no, that's not what I was hoping for. I can't go in there
*Mark screams* *Animatronic yell*
OH my god
I was so close
To the door. Oh
Oh hi, okay
Hello, hi
I'm in the furnace!
OH NO!
We come from the fire
Okay, so there must be like whoa. What the fuck, okay? I got a hook
I don't know what this means, but I got it okay ah
To ignite our flame, so do I put this in the furnace? Is that what you want from me?
Is that what you want from me? Oh?
Ah okay. That's in the furnace now. Well, that's good to know
So there's gotta be other goober gabbers in here behind the posters, maybe. I mean you do here
Yeah, no
*Animatronic scream and Mark yells*
oh
Didn't expect that, did not expect that, did not expect that, did not expect that, that's not what I expected
I was *drawn out* totally not about that. Are they in there?
ok, no?
Alright then
*Animatronic scream and Mark yells*
I didn't see *drawn out* you
Ahh
Fuck man. I just gotta *Mark moans*
My poor heart can't "taoke" that
Fouck youk.
There we go. There we go!
Why do I hear something?
That's something bad.
*Animatronic yell and Mark screams*
Fucking, I knew something was bad about that. I knew something was bad. God damn it.
Got something oh, hi, okay. How do I get by you when you're right there?
Can I go in here?
Will that make you go away?
Nope, you're still there. Okay. That's a problem
Hmm about that oh
Curious don't like it. Can't get it in there, really
Oh boy
Uhh ee *Mark sounds*
Ee eeh EEH
Yeah, right there. Got it backing away slowly
Okay, all right okay, okay? Yeah, yeah, yeah okay? So just the cupcake is left. I think I don't know where that would be
*Game background noise: fire crackling, wind rushes, faint ringing noise*
It's gone quiet. Wha-  how does that make sense?!
How does it-? *Fire rising noise*
*Metallic child giggle*
How does that make sense? How does that make sense you just gotta wait? Oh?
Okay, I didn't know I needed patience for this. I was just running around frantically with my head chopped off, okay, all right
It made very little sense let's try this again. You got four more to go and that one took a while
"Many shapes all similar but different"
Yeah "All keeping us in here with you"
"The one he calls Michael"
"In the stories he formed"
"Find the key to fit the lock"
"Avoid the one's lost to the fire"
"Give him to us and we promise"
"His kindred to fill your desires"
Okay
All right, who the hell are you talking about and why is someone in there that?
That looks like the shape of somebody and I don't like that oh
Okay, find the key to fit the lock
Oh is it a code?
Oh its code thing isn't it. Alright.
Okay, I see oh I see you there. Don't think I don't see you. Okay, six, nine, two, three? Six, nine, two, three
Is that what it is?
Nope, okay, couldn't have been that simple ah wait, okay the numbers coincide with the number of creatures
Nine, six, three, two is it
Yeah, there we go. I'm not sure I'm too happy about this but there- we go
*shouts* WhaAAAY!
Okay, hi?! DA FUQ?!
Boy oh, hi, okay?
Beedoop
Beeeeeeedoop
Oh, that's not good all righty then hi. Hello. How are you doing? I'm fine
Thank you very much, please go away
Fuck how do I close this goddamn door can I close this goddamn door probably not?
Can't can I? Okay he's right there caught on the door. I don't know where I'm going
Boy that one's in the middle right there
How do I get through this bullshit with him right there?
Oh fuck. Oh, that's no good
Yeah, oh, God, it's uh it's co of course. It's over there. I don't know the code for this one
fuck oh, oh
Okay, ah wait. What's that on the other wall okay? It's a bear with three hearts? Health bags?
Presents? That means nothing, but that one. Oh bear two? Two bear
That that might be foxy. I have no idea that's obviously freddy with three presents. Oh there we go
Bonnie with four, so Freddy at three, Bonnie four, Foxy two, and it leaves Chica with one, right?
Oh, I see, okay
But colored okay, Chica first, Foxy second
Freddy third, Bonnie fourth
What?
Okay, okay, okay, okay?
Open, open, open, open, open, open
Is there something on the other side of that fence let me just get in position where I could see that and him
Does it look like it? I think I got it
Yeah
All right, let's go for this
Hello anybody up the stairs. I should worry about no oh, but there's a blockade. Why is there a blockade? Oh?
God oh wait. Oh, no. Oh, what did I just do oh?
oh
I can close it behind me. Oh, I didn't know I could do that
Okay
That still doesn't help me. Oh, oh the key oh
Oh, I got the key and he's gone
Alrighty then that was weird
Where is he? Is he here?
still here
Okay... weird.
Got the key.
Don't know? I don't know? I don't know? I don't know? I don't know what you want from me. Oh
Okay, where am I now oh boy? Oh boy? This is pipey. I love pipe good thing
you got surplus up pipe because that's my favorite thing to have when I'm in the dark basement fearing for my life
There's something behind me? I there something behind me? Should I look behind me?
Interesting alrighty then pressing forward because I got nothing better to do and I have a funny feeling I'm gonna die
Okay, then keep going okay. Don't look back. I'm not gonna. Look back. Why would I look back? Why would I look back?
I'm not the type of person to look back
No matter what may be behind me. I'm not the type of person to look back, and I'm not gonna look back no matter what you tell me no matter how long how strong. I want to look back. I'm not gonna look back
no way nohow
There's no way in hell that I would ever look back because if I were to look back
And when there's a door right in front of me...
OKAY I LOOKED BACK I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT DID BUT I DID IT!
*Mark screams*
*Animatronic screams and Mark screams*
I shouldn't have looked back. Why did I look back?
*Mark scared tone, yelling*
That's why you don't look back. That's why you don't stupidly look back cuz that'd be dumb that be RURR dumb.
All right number two. Oh that was number three? "We act. We posed. We played. We stopped. We stared. We screamed"
"We bring his visions to life"
"Because that is how much we live, feeding from the joy of creation, and bringing what remains"
Hi Golden Freddy- Oh "He remains"
*the scared markimoo is scared for his life*
*loudly and drawn out, gets increasingly louder each time*
Ah!
*yelling* Ah!
What do I uh?
What do I do about this?
yupy
yupy oh boy that is
Is not good oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god, oh god. Go through the middle here
Is there someone behind me is it just the two of them?
oh
Oh, hi, oh, God
*Mark yells, scared tone*
Okay, all right. We're fine. Fine. There's a button over there. I'm gonna press that that's nice nice button.
Oh hi, what the fuck!
You're telling me
Another one of those goddamn assholes over here
Fuck
oh
Hi, oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my god. Oh my God, okay? All right, okay? All right, okay?
I got this I got this I know what to do. I know what to do. Oh like a butterfly
Like a butterFLYYYY!!!!
Holy shit. I saw that move man
That's bidoof men things, but hooven nobody you guys stay over there. I'm gonna go up this stairs now
Maybe I'm going up the stairs now. Holy shit balls
And ass cock oh, did I get the key did I do it? Oh?
oh *child laughter*
No door. Oh, we're in no door land. Oh, no door. No door hold the door no door
We ain't going nowhere whore door.  The furnace is gone
That button do nothing I got a bad feeling about this
Just like everything in this basement. Surprisingly, I know. I have a bad feeling about this oh
Everything's go *burps* on excuse me pardon me. Sorry. I know that was rude
fear burps and all that
One more puzzle to get through? I don't know
If you think about the logic of this like none of this makes any sense, it's all in his mind
For Scott, on Scott's mind. Oh that is dark
Okay
All right, then this silly
Hello. Oh, it's his computer
Look he's making some fred boy. Oh, there isn't even a door there anymore. There was nothing in the first place. It's all ruse
Why is this open? I don't like the fact that this is open.
I made it
"Simple tricks of the mind or something more sinister"
I don't know? "Accounts of these strange apparitions present and all the way back since ancient egyptian mythology telling chilling tales
Ghostly doubles with sightings
Usually precede horrible tragedy for the people whose faces they stolen, we interview many who claim to have seen or experienced these encounters of their own evil twin."
Own Evil Twin
Oh, I don't know what that means
*high pitched yelling*I don't know what that means?! Ugh, I don't know what that means.
But either way that is the end of the basement all that is left is the attic I called it
I knew it and somehow
I don't feel any better for it because I see a little Golden Freddy plushie you right there in the doorway
This game is amazing. I love this game like I said I would have paid money for this. This is so well made
It's so well made. Oh my God, but either way. Thank you everybody so much for watching. Hope you enjoyed this one
Let me know what you think down the comments below and as always I will see you in the next video
Bye, bye!
*outro music plays*